hi everyone thanks for tuning in
this will be an itcs 2022 talk on
discrepancy theory
my name is makran and this is a joint
work with nikhil bhansal hathiyan jiang
raghu mecca and sahil singla
so let me start by introducing the
vector balancing problem which will be
the focus of this talk
so in this problem
you are given vectors v one through v t
t vectors they are
d dimensional vectors
and they all have euclidean norm at most
one
and our goal is to partition these
vectors into two classes so they are
roughly balanced
so one of the most popular problems
about balancing vectors is the so-called
kombucha conjecture
which asks whether we can assign these
vectors plus or minus signs
so that when you add these vectors with
the corresponding assigned signs
the infinity norm of that vector which i
will also call the discrepancy vector
is a constant
so if you assign these signs randomly
the infinite norm could be as large as
square root t
but the convolution conjecture asks
whether you can make each coordinate of
this sign some vector
to be constant
so this is a very famous problem in
discrepancy theory and it's a very
strong conjecture
and it implies several other well-known
conjectures for instance the backfield
conjecture
as well as other you know popular
results like spencer's theorem
which you might have heard of
so the best known
upper bound we have towards this problem
is due to banashik who in a very nice
result showed that the discrepancy
or the infinity norm of the sign sum
vector
is at most root log of the dimension d
plus root log of the number of vectors t
so
this is
the best we know so far and there is no
known lower bound as far as we know this
conjecture combustion conjecture could
be true
so this is the vector balancing problem
about
this final sign sum vector
let me introduce the variant of this
problem which would be the prefix
discrepancy problem
so here we
not only care about the final sign some
vector but also about all prefixes of it
so
if you stop at any point t little t
in 1 to t
and look at all the vectors
until that point and with the
corresponding signs
what is the
minimum
infinity norm of any prefix vector
and surprisingly uh the best upper bound
for this problem
uh is the same as
for the kombucha problem
this is again due to banashik it's
square root log d plus square root log t
so
essentially looking at the final prefix
uh final sign some vector or all
prefixes so far doesn't make a
difference in this mount
i mean the proof is different but the
final bound is remains the same
so this is again a very natural problem
in discrepancy theory
but it also
has connections to other problems
for instance it implies bound for
another very famous problem called the
studies problem and it has several
applications in integer programming and
approximation algorithms
so our focus on this talk will be uh
understanding this prefix discrepancy
problem
so what kind of uh
constraints
uh having
prefixes in the problem
put on
our algorithm or our bound
so some motivating questions
uh that we'll consider in the stock are
the following
so first is banashi expound optimal if
we consider all prefixes or can you
prove a lower bound
maybe it's much harder to prove a lower
bound for the homeless problem which
only considers the final pre final sign
some vector
but maybe
it's easier to prove a lower bound for
the prefix discrepancy problem
or maybe there is a better upper bound
here
and the second very natural
question that one can consider
is the following
so
if you look at the prefixes of the
vectors one through t
one can view this as a ordering uh based
on the line graph which is just the path
between 1 to t
but we can consider other orderings
between these vectors
given by like a
tree or a dag
and the corresponding topological order
on this bag or the tree
and one can ask what if we consider
prefixes
that are given by this tree or this tag
uh what is the best bound one can hope
for in this setting the spanish expands
still hold here or not
and lastly
you know one needn't stop at a prefixes
of a tree or a dag
one can ask you know what if the
discrepancy constraints are given by an
arbitrary set system
and
we introduced this problem
which we call the combinatorial
discrepancy problem
and this generalizes
all the other other questions
and
it also connected to some
previously studied notions of
discrepancy theory and we will see that
uh later in this talk
so these are the motivating questions
for this talk
so
what do we prove uh in this work
so first
towards understanding whether banashi
expound is optimal for the prefix
discrepancy problem
we show that this is not true in a
smoothed setting
where you're allowed to add a small
noise to the vector
so if you perturb your vector by adding
a small noise
and the noise here could be quite
general all we need is that the
covariance matrix of the random noise
vector you're adding
has a
sufficiently
small
projection in each direction
so the projection is at least uh epsilon
or something
so in this case
uh we can show that one can improve the
banashi
bound exponentially in the number of
vectors t
so the bound is root log d plus root log
log t with high probability over the
random noise
for instance if number of vectors is
exponential in the dimension then this
gives you an exponential improvement
so the smoothest setting here this also
captures
the random setting where each of these
vectors are chosen iid from some
distribution
and which has been studying
studied recently in relation to several
uh long-standing open problems in
discrepancy theory
so this bound also applies to a random
setting as well
and we also show that this bound for the
smoothest setting the root log v plus
root log log t
this is optimal uh even for a completely
random instance here
assuming you cannot improve banashik's
bound in the worst case so if vanessa
expound for prefix discrepancy is
optimal then our bound with root log log
t
plus root log d cannot be improved
so this is our first result
so let me
try to tell you briefly what goes into
showing such a result
so let me call this quantity here
in question to be delta
so
we are given t vectors
so and we want to give them plus minus
signs we want to color them
so what we will do first is we will
partition these vectors into blocks or
batches of
m vectors each where m will be
polynomial in d in logarithmic and t
and now one can color the first block
of m vectors here using vanishing result
and since there are just m vectors
this will
give us root log t plus root log log t
bound just for the for any prefix of the
first block
and for coloring the rest of the blocks
we adopt a iterative strategy
we will first find a fractional coloring
of the block
which means that
we will give a
number between -1 and 1 which will
interpret as a fractional color
satisfying some constraints which will
be linear constraints so
these linear constraints what we would
like to see are the following
first you know once we reach the end of
each block
then the fractional discrepancy with
that color
assigned to that block reaches zero so
after we have
reached the end of a block
with the corresponding fractional color
assigned the discrepancy becomes zero so
all the entire discrepancy has been
cancelled out
and if we look at
within each block and
all the previous blocks
that come before that block then this is
discrepancies at most delta
so these are two linear constraints uh
that
and we find a fractional coloring
satisfying these two constraints
and then once we have such a fraction
coloring then you can round this
fractional coloring by interpreting this
number between minus one and one as a
and using some bit by bit rounding this
is
similar to an algorithm of flowage
spencer investor gambi that is used in
rounding uh
linear discrepancy and hereditary
discrepancy
so this only incurs a factor of
2 the surrounding so the total
discrepancy we achieve is at most 2
delta
hence our bound
and the key
challenge or the key lemma we prove
towards uh
proving this uh
towards analyzing this algorithm
is to show that these linear constraints
which gives us an lp
these are satisfiable with high
probability over the random noise we're
adding
this is a very technical part of the
proof
and this relies on some very nice
arguments
using lp duality
and some chaining arguments because
naive indian bound is not enough to
to show that this
lp is feasible with hyperbolic
so i will not have any time to go into
more details about this
lemma so if you're interested please
check out the paper
so this is the
uh
result about the first problem about
another understanding whether banash's
bound is optimal or not
so what about if we consider prefixes of
a tree or a tag
for instance if we are given a rooted
tree and we are given two dimensional
vectors at least because one dimension
is trivial
then we show that banashik's bounds
still hold in this setting so we are
able to show that the discrepancy for
any such prefix is bounded by root log t
plus root log d same as vanishing
but in this set case this bound is tight
it cannot be improved if you consider
prefixes of a tree
and this is tight even for a random
instance
so
i'm ignoring some
log log factors here when i'm saying
this
but this boundary is essentially tight
even for a random instance
so
the prefixes of a tree or a dagger they
impose some natural constraints which
can
allows you
[Music]
uh
which makes you stuck at this point
so what about the general dag
so for general tag
let's consider a very simple example
first just to understand what's going on
so suppose our vectors are just one
dimension so they're scalars and they're
just zero one vectors
and our dag is the following dag
looks like this
so now
we want the prefixes of this dag to be
balanced
for instance the bottom most most part
we should assign it
plus and minus science so that is
roughly balanced
but if you do that then
consider the
the any of the top vertices and consider
the majority color for instance let's
say it's plus
so now if we have a path with sort of
short circuits all the minuses in the in
the top layer then this path must have
discrepancy that is linear in t
so in this case we are very far off from
root log d plus root log t bound because
the discrepancy
for some prefix must be omega t
so
this suggests that this bound of root
log t plus root log t is not
the right quantity to compare it to
so
for a general dag there are many more
constraints the number of paths can be a
lot more
so what is the right bound here
so
as we'll see in a second the right bound
will be
coming from what's called the hereditary
discrepancy
so let me introduce this notion which is
a very well studied notion in
discrepancy theory
so let me start by defining the
discrepancy of a set system first so
suppose you are given a set system or in
on the universe 1 through t
and our goal is to give science to the
elements of this universe so that each
set
have
as
so each set has uh roughly equal number
of pluses and minuses
so we want to minimize the imbalance
among all sets so minimize over all
choices of signs
the maximum imbalance of each set
so this quantity i will call the
discrepancy of the set system or this
set family
so the heritage discrepancy of a set
system
is the maximum overall projections of
the universe if you project our universe
onto some elements and consider the
induced set system on that
on the projection
what is the discrepancy of the set
system
and the heritage discrepancy is the
maximum over all such projections
so why is this the right notion to look
at for instance
if you look at this dag that we just saw
before
and our set system is all the prefixes
of this path
of this tag
so all paths and all prefixes of such
paths
then it's not very difficult to show
that the hereditary discrepancy of this
set system is linear in t which matches
what we were seeing before
and if we consider a different tag for
instance this very simple dag which is
just a path
then the hereditary discrepancy of this
particular set system which is the
prefix of this dial is just constant
so this gives us a very nice way to
generalize banasik results from not just
prefixes of a tree but to an arbitrary
tag in the following day
we show that for if we are given any dag
and we want to
maximize the minimize the discrepancy
with respect to all prefixes of this tag
which can have a lot more path than a
tree
then the right quantity to compare it to
is the hereditary discrepancy and the
bound we give
the discrepancy in the setting for any
arbitrary b dimensional vectors
is bounded by the hereditary discrepancy
of the underlying set system prefix of
the dag
times root log d plus root log t
so for instance if g was a rooted tree
or a path then hereditary discrepancy is
constant so this generalizes the
previous results
so how do we
prove this
so there's some very nice ideas that go
into proving this
but the key level here is to sort of
reduce the case of an arbitrary dag to
that of a tree
and this involves this nice
combinatorial characterization of paths
in a dag
so we show that in any dag g
there is always a rooted spanning tree
such that any path
in this bag
has only few non tree edges
the number of non tree edges is uh just
heritage discrepancy
of the
threat system of prefix of g all
prefixes
so basically
and how do we show this
uh so one can show this inductively
by showing
by working backwards from the
topological order ensuring that whenever
the number of non-tree edges increase by
some amount
then we can find uh
such a chain
structure
which is this following graph with one
additional link so with one additional
triangle
and if you have so if you find such a
chain structure
then it also implies that the heritage
discrepancy also increases so you can
charge the number of non-tree edges to
the heritage discrepancy
so once we have this lemma we can sort
of split
uh the case of arbitrary dag to
[Music]
uh hereditary discrepancy many disjoint
trees
and for a
rooted tree we can show that banastic
spawn still holds in the setting
and we knew do this by generalizing uh
the convex geometric arguments that that
were used by banashik so
we generalize them to show that this
root log t plus root log t bound holds
not just for a prefixes of a path but
even for a rooted tree
and this gives a
gives us a result for the tag
and
to show that this
bound is tied for
uh for trees
uh we can construct a very nice low
bound example which is pretty simple
and let me just give you some uh key
points here
so
for instance let's say we want to
we are given a tree and we want to
assign vectors to this tree let's say
this is just a complete tree the
uh complete carry tree
we will just assign two dimensional
vectors to each vertex of this tree
and i will ensure that along every path
down the tree the vectors will always be
orthogonal
so the squared euclidean norm will
always increase along every path
so basically
uh
if we have a binary tree this will give
us this root log t plus root log log t
root log d bound
and
even if you pick these vectors randomly
they will be sufficiently orthogonal
uh at least
you can find such a subtree in a larger
random instance so uh this mount is
tight even for a random instance
so this proves us uh
the result about dag and trees
and what if we consider an arbitrary
system where there is no such a nice
structure
so here we are
again able to relate the discrepancy in
this context when your constraints are
coming from an arbitrary set system
to the heritage hereditary discrepancy
but uh the
with the polylog factors in not only d
and t but also the
size of the set family of the set system
and
to show this we actually sort of show
that the discrepancy
uh in this combinatorial discrepancy
problem with respect to arbitrary such
system can be bounded
in terms of
the gamma two norm of the threat system
uh times root uh certain times some
polylog factors and d and the cardinal
cardinality of s the set family
okay
so
i'm not going to define the gamma two
normal matrix is some particular norm
that you can define for a matrix uh
which would be the incidence matrix of
the set system here
and it is uh
well known here that
gamma 2
norm and heritage discrepancy
are related by at most logarithmic
factors so they
so that's how we
get our result
so to summarize
uh
first we looked at whether banashi's
bound is optimal for the prefix
discrepancy problem and we show that
this is not true in a smoothed setting
the bound can be improved exponentially
in the number of vectors t
and this is
tight assuming banashi's bound is tight
in the worst case
and but if we consider prefixes of a
tree or a dag uh then
uh we can prove bound in terms of
heritage to discrepancy
which uh generalizes monash expound
and this bound here this bound is tied
so you cannot improve this even in a
random setting even for a tree
lastly we looked at the combinatorial
discrepancy problem where we again were
able to prove
show that discrepancy constraints uh
coming from an arbitrary system
one can still bound uh this quantity in
terms of the heritability discrepancy
with the worst polylog factors uh where
there's a parameter of
cardinality of the search system as well
so that's a summary of our results let
me conclude with some open problems
so one very natural question that's
still left open by our work is
whether the prefix version of the
congress problem is true or not
whether if you look at all
prefixes
of the final discrepancy vector
can you find sign so that the infinity
norm is constant
so we show that uh
uh
yeah this is
still uh possible as far as we know
and one can also ask
you know i mean through that analysis is
a
nice uh
idea in its own so one can ask you know
for some of these long-standing problems
like homosexual bacterial conjectures
can we prove them in a smoother model
so
recently there has been a lot of work in
understanding these problems in random
setting where all these vectors are
completely random
where we know that some of these
conjectures are true in some regime of
parameters
but what about if we are giving a worst
case instance and we are adding a random
noise
this will sort of at least clarify as
you know some kind of structure on the
uh the lower bound instances of these
problems
and third you know for this uh
combinatorial discrepancy problem where
your constraints are given by an any
arbitrary set system
a bound had a polylog factors uh which
also depended on the size of the set
system
said family which could be very large
so one can ask you know whether uh
this bound can be improved to just the
heritage discrepancy times
uh
root log t plus root log t which is
banana shakespeare
times the heritage discrepancy factor
as far as we know uh this could be true
and this will generalize our
results from a dag to any arbitrary set
system
lastly we're always
a question of can we prove algorithmic
guarantees for any of these results
so
some of the most of the results in the
stock
uh can be made algorithmic up to an
additional log factor so
what can we achieve the root log t plus
root log t bounds for
within one element and algorithm that
remains a very interesting open problem
so
that's it i will conclude with that
thank you very much and thanks for
listening